[Música]
colombia es un destino conocido para
quienes buscan practicarse una cirugía
estética sin embargo la alta demanda por
ese tipo de procedimientos en el país no
se traduce en algunos casos en una buena
práctica pacientes en su mayoría mujeres
mueren víctimas de dichas intervenciones
según la sociedad internacional de
cirugía plástica estética en colombia se
practicaron
366.000 312 cirugías de este tipo en el
año 2020 las liposucciones y el aumento
de senos fueron las más buscadas sin
embargo la cifra que no es clara es el
número de personas afectadas y también
que fallecieron tras dichos
procedimientos en colombia la falta de
legislación para regular las cirugías
estéticas por lo que aumentan las
denuncias contra ser humanos
constituidos o cuestionados es realmente
preocupante por ello entonces quiero dar
la bienvenida a nuestro primer invitado
al de ayer lorena beltrán ella es
periodista magister en gobierno y
políticas públicas activista por la
reglamentación de los procedimientos
estéticos en colombia además víctima de
un cirujano con título cuestionado
gracias lorena por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france muy buen día
primeramente le quiero preguntar cuál es
el panorama entonces de esta situación
en colombia y también en nuestro
continente en américa latina' nuestra
región porque a pesar de que es algo
conocido por las autoridades y también
las mujeres esto sigue sucediendo a
lorena porque
bueno raúl buenos días buenos días a
todos los televidentes la situación en
este momento en colombia es que somos
uno de los destinos mundiales más
reconocidos en la región para
practicarse este tipo de procedimientos
que pueden ser quirúrgicos o solamente
médicos es decir puede haber
intervención que requiera un quirófano
como hay otros tratamientos tipo
inyectables botox aparatos láser para
moldear los contornos del cuerpo y pese
a la gran oferta y demanda que hay en
nuestro país no hay una legislación
clara sobre qué título deben tener los
profesionales que se dedican a este tipo
de procedimientos esto lo que provoca
pues es que no siempre nuestra oferta
sea la mejor calificada y terminamos
tristemente con pacientes deformes con
pacientes que fallecen en los quirófanos
y desde luego esto también pesa mucho en
la impunidad de estos casos sí porque
ese es otro problema que tenemos es el
sistema judicial como afronta este tipo
de casos
dilaciones en los procesos y finalmente
pues un sistema que no beneficia la
denuncia por parte de las víctimas allá
vamos a llegar lorena pero digamos como
podemos ponerle fin a esta problemática
que comienza a lo mejor en el resto en
las redes sociales en instagram en una
página web luego en estas operaciones en
quirófanos alquilados no en clínicas
pues obviamente altamente capacitadas
con todos los equipos para también a lo
mejor atender a algún tipo de
situaciones que puedan generar
complicaciones también las autoridades
de salud digamos pueden cerrar estos
centros pero luego los médicos digamos
entre comillas vuelven a otro centro de
salud vuelven a operar vuelve a pasar es
como un ciclo vicioso que como se puede
atacar lorena para que finalice
bueno pues sin duda algunas personas en
pacientes por lo menos han denunciado
presunta corrupción entre las propias
entidades regionales de salud que se
encargan desde ya que estos sitios
entonces pues en un país como colombia
donde el índice de percepción de la
corrupción es uno de los más elevados de
la región pues valdría la pena revisar
si esto es así pero más allá de esto
raúl respondiendo concretamente a qué
podemos hacer en colombia hay pocos
cupos en las universidades para estudiar
esta especialidad médica creo yo que
esto ha provocado que ante tanta demanda
algunos profesionales decidan
capacitarse fuera del país algunos lo
hacen de una buena forma en una
universidad que cumple con todos los
requisitos pero otros optan por una
información que no es formal que no es
adecuada ni reconocida y pues esto
termina en graves consecuencias entonces
una buena solución sería que la academia
que las universidades donde se enseña
medicina se plantee en que podemos hacer
para ampliar estos cupos en esta
especialidad médica que es tan demandada
por profesionales de la salud
y también por lo menos por por el lado
de las redes sociales porque es que
también es muy importante el autocuidado
del paciente
y pedirle a redes como instagram que
están allí casi todos los profesionales
que ofrecen estos servicios que así como
manejan el contenido mentiroso de
políticos como donald trump pues también
puedan avisar que estos médicos están
siendo investigados o que tienen muchos
comentarios negativos que ellos mismos
se eliminan porque es que esta es una
táctica muy frecuente y tristemente
cuando yo hablo con pacientes y les
pregunto por qué escogieron al médico si
ya tiene denuncias conocidas y lo bucle
así ya sale denunciado me responden
porque operó a tal modelo porque operó a
tal actriz porque tiene más de 10 mil
seguidores en instagram y esto es lo que
les da confianza entonces creo yo que
también hay que trabajar no solamente
desde la formación médica sino también
desde como los pacientes estamos
abordando a estos médicos en redes
sociales y es que precisamente la orina
eso le quería decir porque pues quiero
ser un poco como abogado del
porque algunas personas pueden decir
bueno pero ella entonces sabiendo que
este médico tenía una mala reputación no
lo eligió porque lo eligió porque a lo
mejor cuando llegó a ese a ese quirófano
vivió algo que le llamó la atención con
él práctico que no le parecía ético
perdón que no le parecía como que todo
estuviera en orden porque no salió usted
como víctima y que vivió esa situación o
sea que le dice esas personas porque en
ese momento las personas no actúan a lo
mejor por miedo quiero entender un poco
qué pasa en la cabeza de las personas
cuando están en esa situación
bueno pues es que las pacientes yo en
este momento llevo seis años de
denunciar este tipo de situaciones y en
estos seis años me ha aprendido un
montón de términos resulta que es
diferente un médico cirujano que un
médico estético un médico cirujano
plástico un médico dermatólogo hay un
montón de términos que confunden a la
gente sí y estas personas han
aprovechado esos vacíos para agregarse
títulos que en colombia no existen como
por ejemplo se presentan como soy
cirujano cosmético soy cirujano estético
y las pacientes generalmente no saben
diferenciar entre un término y otro es
que de hecho raúl si yo se lo pregunto
en este momento probablemente usted no
lo sepa seguramente no tengo ya de una
exacta seguramente no entonces como
pacientes muchas veces pasa esto la
desinformación y hace que muchas veces
escojan un hablador ultimado porque
resulta que les dice que tiene 20
títulos y tiene una pared tapizada de
diplomas y esto les genera confianza
pero a la hora de la verdad son títulos
que no son reconocidos por la comunidad
científica en colombia pero sí debo
reconocer
todo este tiempo ha sido un común
denominador la respuesta de confía en él
porque operó a esta influencia confíe en
él porque operó a esta modelo y eso es
algo que deben tener claro todos los
televidentes en este momento y es que el
número de seguidores en redes sociales
no es un indicador de que usted esté en
unas buenas manos porque fui yo cuando
voy no sé al ginecólogo oa cualquier
otro médico no me pongo a fijarme
cuántos seguidores tiene mi ginecólogo
en redes sociales sino sencillamente
tiene una certificación de una clínica
para poder ejercer
lorena 20 segunditos no quiero que se me
quede esto por fuera porque el congreso
colombiano entonces todavía no toma
medidas sobre esta problemática tan
grave
porque intereses muy poderosos detrás
raúl la industria de la belleza es una
de las más poderosas en colombia esto no
es un secreto para nadie nosotros
recibimos pacientes de todo el mundo que
vienen a modificar su apariencia a
colombia y esto no es ningún pecado si
la autonomía de las mujeres sobre su
propio cuerpo esto no está en discusión
debemos elevar las garantías para que
ninguna mujer ni extranjera ni
colombiana ni en ningún lado
tenga que sufrir lesiones debido a la
falta de control que hay en el país pero
en el congreso cinco veces se ha hundido
este proyecto de ley por falta de
voluntad política por lobby porque lo he
visto en directo yo estado las acciones
de discusión en el congreso y he visto
el lobby en el congreso de la república
también lo han denunciado senadores y
representantes a la cámara pues lorena
muchísimas gracias él le mando un abrazo
muy fuerte gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo de france24 y
ojalá pues el congreso colombiano haga
algo al respecto para que no sean las
mujeres nuevamente víctimas de estos
procesos
gracias raúl estábamos conversando con
el general tram periodista magister en
gobierno y también políticas públicas
además activista por la reglamentación
de los procedimientos estéticos en
colombia y víctima de un cirujano con un
título pues entrecomillado cuestionado